hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to baldies basics and
education and learning now this game was
highly highly highly recommended by you
guys you said that I absolutely had to
play this game and if you clicked on
this and you've never seen this game
before in your life you're ready well I
mean I actually don't know what's going
on inside but I know there's more than
meets the eye whereas mouse left click
right click scroll wheel shift run watch
your stamina spacebar look behind you
and wave goodbye to your friends I don't
like that this story everybody listen
close oh Noah's school is out but your
friend has a problem he left all his
note boos in high school but doesn't
have time to go get them because if he
do he'll be late for eating practice a
to help him out you have to go back in
the school and find all seven of his
notebooks for him it won't be easy
though Baldy loves challenging his
students with fun trivia problems
whenever he can each time you find a
notebook you'll have to answer some
questions answer all three correctly and
you'll earn a prize find all seven
notebooks and then the exit to school to
win all right that doesn't make a whole
lot of sense it's like Sunderman but
with the horrible teacher that wants to
quiz you to death okay let's do this
[Music]
ah hello Baldy nothing seems to be out
of the ordinary cell the child rapper I
probably should have you know up the
sensitivity who you are horrifying
okay sorry teach I didn't expect to just
go through you all right school rules
when you follow the school rules no
running no entering faculty no eating no
drinking no escaping detention no fourth
wall breaks oh hi oh I don't like the
way you follow me all doom style also I
don't know what to win the music thank
you why is this your school that doesn't
make any sense okay whoo ha ha ha
math it's like math blaster
it's like Mavis Beacon teaches typing
I win
did I get my friends notebook and why do
I have to do that
[Music]
find something you can use it on right
click okay Bobby
by balding Thank You Bobby I'll be on my
way Baldy oh all right sure sorry I ran
out of time to add more subjects is it
all math then
[Music]
0o baldy baldy baldy baldy whose ass are
you slapping over there oh hi
okay alright what hey whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey
oh my ass is not prepared for that kind
of 15 seconds
holy tension for you or no when will you
learn i I don't know where you went okay
alright then hmm okay all right oh he's
a he's a slapping he's a sloppy slapper
oh I might be in trouble okay all righty
then
Oh okay one more slap and now I'm gonna
go around slap okay all right slap okay
all right here comes another one okay
okay - huh 12
Oh zero got it here every door you open
that's fine
it is like Slendy man it is like slanty
man jump Rob
why did what is that a spyglass what
hell happened to me oh all right
education and hahahaha okay all right
welcome
how about what happens to bike for zero
oh he didn't like that
zero zero I get angry or for every
problem you get wrong
oh no he's already unhappy with me okay
all right it's fine it's fine
if I could just get around these goddamn
things okay three negative four zero
okay well this is a problem hmm okay is
he gonna come this way is he gonna mmm
don't spank my rump
oh he's angry oh he's I got stuck on uh
I got I got stuck okay all right Baldy
okay alright baldies go yeah I think the
hall monitor was for running in the
halls and I don't I don't want to run in
the halls ooh
and that's why I can look behind me with
your spacebar to kiss my ass good-bye
[Music]
okay can I get it there's another
notebook homestar runner reference okay
this is uh 13 that's 11 dad zero okay
guys go we gotta go we only got three of
seven this is gonna be loud
oh boy use it Hey
how close is he how close is he how
close is he to spanking my ass oh far I
was gonna be fine
okay you you you slappy piece of [ __ ]
all right
run around the Rosie pocket full of posy
and I'm out okay if I just don't run I
should be fine look by me oh that's not
good okay it's fine
yeah all right going into a new area
school faculty only maybe I should go in
here that's not okay I got some faculty
key all right well thank you for telling
me here I think detention for you okay
if my if my parents would be happy if I
make it out alive you know to be
perfectly honest oh I'm so screwed okay
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm not
no oh [ __ ] not here oh no oh no okay
school faculty only I don't think I've
been in here zette tape but I saw oh no
oh no I saw a cassette player
I need to rest okay
all right so you only rest when you stop
okay good
okay who wears this but it was it was
what if I can do this for you
wait uh here we go
Oh Oh my ass is grass I don't know what
that's all about my my ass is grass I
think I'm okay okay fine again don't
know what that's all about but okay I
need to go left
[Music]
okay this is a poly please don't bully
me okay oh wow that is weird
all right all right whoa I'm not doing
nothing you were doing something 9 a 2-0
okay this is fine it's fine I've got
four of seven and four seven sounds bird
oh man that's slap okay all right I'm
not going by the bully yeah I guess the
bully wants my money
maybe the bully wants money cuz I got
money I don't know what else to give the
bully
okay whatever get in here what the hell
kind of cafeteria is this oh okay all
right Cola okay I don't have much mmm
ob soda okay I got to just kind of get
some space behind me recycling for you I
wasn't in the hall I was not in her
weight Shayan tries to be avoided
doesn't like being looked at and gets
jealous at people with more notebooks in
them
okay well that's me oh this blah blah
okay so I got it he's got not run in the
hall
we're going for it no running in the
halls that's only if the dude can see me
so if I just don't let him see me whoa
whoa you went through my body and I'm
not okay with that
all right I don't need anything in there
okay let's just ignore that we're gonna
get the principal's keys eventually but
not immediately now hey Bobby I'm not
running oh oh okay I'm gonna try to
avoid that guys out a giant Nokia cell
phone in front of me or am I going
absolutely batshit crazy anything in
here another shiny quarter
I like quarter I like a shiny quarter oh
no I can't reach that no I don't want to
go around there's a mistake hmm today's
lesson how to eat cheese I like that
kind of lesson oh okay another classroom
on the left which is good okay just got
it
mm-hmm you know him over there 25 cents
for the phone I don't know what the
phone would do Wow
what does Wow mean were you impressed by
my amazing math skills
3:9 okay he's there that's fine though
let's see what happens when I use this
maybe it's not a good idea to corner
myself like that if I was just thinking
about something maybe that would be a
bad idea I'm gonna grab one of these
soda pops though I got to find out
what's at the end of this hall before I
go the other way I think I've got some
time
this is loop around or is this just a
big dead-end because if it's a big
dead-end I'm gonna be very pissed what
is that dude unknown reason do you have
absolutely nothing to do with games I'm
secure school faculty cannot currently
see through windows okay well that's
good though right oh hi oh yay the world
is big class dismissed
oh good okay all right negative four
negative six yeah forever problems okay
but this is fine we're making good
progress we've got four that's good run
here hopefully that guy doesn't arrive
is that good or bad is that good for me
or bad for me I'm gonna try to give this
bully a quarter but if I can't give the
bully a quarter I'm gonna be ooh Oh
hee-hee hi Bali hi would you like a
quarter okay dog dab again and I don't
know
13:11 zero oh no I'm gonna be in trouble
because he's gonna be scooching behind
me real fast now but I got five or seven
that's problem whoa-ho that's a problem
oh oh oh that is oh that's extreme this
is what I call one of those problems
I'm not running I would never even think
of running yeah I said thinking of
running I'm currently thinking of
extremely running oh I'm thinking of
running okay all right III need I wasn't
I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't I was not
I wasn't Oh No please no no no no no no
maybe this is good pitches for you maybe
this is good okay what do you do when
the school opened seven hour you haven't
hired two janitor hire a broom and
sweets to everything I don't know that's
a good thing or a bad thing no there's
good or bad whatever that is I wonder if
anybody actually knows what that what
what if I wonder if there's like a
correct answer for that one
in particular because if there it'll eat
the deep deep anything in there
I don't do anything I think I'm I saw
the printer
oh no no nine six okay cool
we're making good progress there's only
one left and then we just got to give
out and I've already got the principle
key so if it's hidden behind like the
principle key or something I'm in good
shape
oh why no no oh that's too fast
oh that's too fast oh that is oh oh no
no no no no no how envy flying [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna lock him in here
okay he got locked so he has to go the
long way around so if there's the affair
if there's so I'm gonna make this one
the last I'm gonna make these two the
last ones I do because it's a straight
shot to the door after
no no not yet
do not play with me I will be very
pissed off oh no I think I 1581 zero I
think I think he's coming down the the
straight and narrow but this is the last
one so if I can just it's not fair
education and learning that's not you
can't just do that to me that's not fair
you root you changed where I was somehow
I was here right by it but that didn't
make any sense so I don't know just Oh
shitty dicks shitty titty dicks shitty
titty dicks shitty titty dicks no no
please tell me he's not right there
these two this is to exit I'm done so
I'm done I'm done so tone avoid using no
no no no okay don't you even think about
it
okay okay I got him locked out oh are
you I shouldn't have used the soda I
probably could have made that without
that he's going around but I don't think
he's gonna be able to make it in time
for me to get that I'm gonna get this
last one I've got nothing
though which is a big problem so I just
don't know I don't know where he's gonna
be based after I get this last one if
he's like decides to be a dick you know
like like the freakin whistle man okay I
got all of them let's see where it puts
him see where it puts me Oh so
[Music]
no no no no no I just got I just got to
do the same thing I did again like
pretty much I've got the strategy down
so there's not much else to it this is
it's just straight up the same thing so
long as I can get it perfect without
getting interrupted without jumping rope
getting in the way I should be fine
oh I get it Baldy you're incredibly
disappointed the end game looks like
insanity if they're gonna be moving if
they're gonna be moving the exit like
that I'm going to need absolutely 100%
I'm gonna need to go I'm gonna need to
save both of these soda cans so that I
can get away from them because if it's
just a series of long hallways then I
can just blast him constantly like that
and then I can get out of here Oh who's
trying to call me not now I'm in the
middle of Baldy no oh do not I don't
know if he's gonna get in this room
he's perfect unless that sweeper puts
him right next to me what you might 10
14 okay here we go this is it and then I
just go towards the I know where the
exit is okay I think I got this he's way
away and I know where the exit is you
cannot fool me I know exactly where it
is it's right here this is the exit oh
no little girl no no no I will push you
away with soda little girl I will put
you you get away from me not know what
no no no no no how know you I thought it
was a trick I thought it would be the
real one were the real ones if I had
just gone to the other one first nope
not today buddy
okay he's gonna go a long way back for
that one
here's another exit quote-on-quote we'll
see what this one actually does if it's
something to do with the pleura
principles keys I'm gonna be so
dad
and
what the [ __ ] no sir no winning sir
[Music]
that's me do I have to look up a guide
how to beat this so what you have to do
is you have to trigger all of them you
have to do all and then you're free so I
got three I got three of the four in the
last ones in the cafeteria six of seven
doing well
it's coming around the cool no no you
[ __ ] [ __ ] do not oh my god do not
do not do not oh my god oh my god no no
no no well there goes every possibility
of me actually doing what I needed to do
which is [ __ ] gone but at least I'm
still alive I didn't know if that would
be able to do it but I'm still like as
soon as I get around this corner I'm I'm
done
[Music]
yeah okay so I need a different route
cuz that's not working okay
this might be it just got a play
perfectly okay so I've got this what I'm
gonna do is when I get around here he's
coming quick but I think I've got enough
space I just need to lock this door
[Music]
[ __ ] god damn it tight again oh it's
the girl - okay but we still both on the
same side which means that I could
potentially lock them both down well
it's gonna be close ah yes okay got it
nailed it holy [ __ ]
I've got nothing for that guy to take
but I know various
if I go in here there's a candy bar
right here
this
[Music]
I could have [ __ ] made it
God might have gone for the chocolate
instead of it [ __ ] damn it
ah this is just just so [ __ ] angry
that was a they've just gone for the
chocolate instead which is a good god
[ __ ] idea this is infuriating is the
thing it's just infuriating it's just a
non-stop cavalcade of it's just cuz it's
my favorite thing in games luck-based
it's rng based it's are you gonna get
the jump rope girl ten million times
you're gonna get her once
you gotta get the bully standing in your
way you're gonna get the sock man the
sock man wasn't there this time so I
could have lucked out I could have
Cruise died so much time I had all the
time in the world and yet there I was
dead in the water
god dammit he's cutting off the only way
I can go
god damn it if it-- if he wasn't right
there I would have made this god [ __ ]
damn it
if you if I didn't get in detention I
would have had that one if I didn't run
when I shouldn't have run I would have
had that one that one was mine for the
[ __ ] taking that one was mine god
[ __ ] damn it I honestly think I might
have had a chance there is buddy yeah
I I can only do one more try I literally
can only do one more try
that's all I can scribe I'm approaching
three hours now and I'm not not going to
complete you I'm not going to do this
[Music]
detention for you
Tandi that was really handy thank you
for that honestly thank you for that
that was really what I needed because
they were harassing me like you wouldn't
believe
all right I've got a second lease on
this which is shocking I know
but there's only so much you can ask for
there's only so much that you can get so
that's like the only bit of luck so my
last try I've got some luck now if I
could just not be stupid Oh [ __ ] no
you really just did those I shouldn't
have said a goddamn thing about the luck
you've got you've gotta be [ __ ] I
can't I can't deal with it
that's so ridiculous that's beyond
anything I'm gonna get this ganbara heat
it so that I can run this might be the
most ridiculous attempt that's ever
happened to me I lost my [ __ ] soda
easily the weirdest run I've ever had
please sweet man give me just a little
bit of loveliness just sweeper you've
been
[Music]
Sweeper man just gonna okay here we go
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
yes yes yes [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you piece
of [ __ ] oh my god and it discloses the
game but that's fine we just [ __ ] good
[ __ ] god that game I'm done I'm outta
here I got goin dinner now it's Amy's
birthday and happy birthday Amy don't
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you enjoyed that like button thank
you let me know what you thought down in
the comments below if you want it for
some reason play this game a pal I'll
put a link to it in the description
below but I get it yeah so thank you
everybody so much for watching
Australia that's right Australia and New
Zealand and Amsterdam
we're comedy you go to tour tomorrow
mark on this link in the description see
you there thank you
I'm out die and as always I'll see you
in the next video bye bye
you